前回のお話
なんか山田境駅にめっちゃ怒られたんで質問コーナー一緒にトランって聞いてみたら
5本結構6ちゃう
そうですね着に多い協力できることをしようですから無茶をちょっ
ん
とって
俺がいいて本当にやってくれるのであれこれだっ帰ったらやらないでしょ
て言っていません
[音楽]
いや二じょうじゆつ選んでくださいいいですかぁ無茶はしないわ
わかりました山中ができる範囲で言って
ん所協力させていただきます
ゆっいい
ええええええ
[音楽]
voodoo
ん
ご紹介しますもうボーダーれ邪魔だね
0じゃあじゃあまず何から何かいっそ椅子に座ってていいんですか今一番コラボした
ユーチューバーさんは山田さんそもそも youtube 見られます
見てみますよ局の表コラボ
これはもって難しいけど photo 者さん
の源氏香めちゃめちゃですパパッと作っ
声いいでしょうねーなーかっこいいですねー結構見てますよ
どうぞよろしくお願いしますティッシュ食べちゃいな
あったアーティストはすっいやーなんだか言っただろう他なお真蛮は骨ボタンないです
このもバイロンあるほど値じゃないんですかねこれ
1国家だけだから大丈夫なんですけど変な質問しないようですよちょっと食べてくれる
僕の指はここに生きるんです
きデー
程度あゆみなんでしょうね君
箱根駅伝にてる名前までも箱に入れる
夢は必ず実現できる日々精進努力は裏切らないと思ってください
坊主にしてください
だ誰だからさんはそんなに大丈夫な結局を述べました
売ってたりするから言われたいと思いますほらは仕事営業前の全体ジョブ全然た以上に
1回かしていろいろ g 結果1回汚れしてってね貯金チェックして大
これより興味深いです
財布はハーセヒメダカ9万3000円塗装
[音楽]
ひぁっあらじゃあヌー一応二キュロスは僕が今発生
でした
水2リットル難病で述べるん
フィットさせる良いと思うよっ
皆さんじゃん
んだぞ山崎まさよさんあのこの後仕事に影響はでるでますなものを持つテレビではさん
どうぞ
誰
逃げたらない日はなかったすみません
こんなこともそうですね
バイトどうしたら頑張れますか03倍とされたことあります
あのファストフードハンバーガー店で昔したようなことがありますまあ時間15歳から
の時中学卒業して大中央線という新聞判決やってました
結構倍とされている言わでもそれだけその後の俳優やってますね俳優の仕事やりたいっ
ていう気持ちは
あったからすでにもうそれをやるためだけでもなんとか仕事を決まるまでの間我慢って
いう気持ちでやってましたねあーなるほどでも結局大人になってから俳優すって言って
ますけど
いろんなバイトを持って行ってればよかったなと思いましたすごいいい社会勉強になる
のでそうですよね
んでそれぞれまあ印象だったの接客だったりとかいろんなスキルたびにつけられるから
大変ですけどなんかそこでいろんなものはどんどん身についていると思ったら頑張れ
みたいですかねはい
頑張ってくださいほっぺたぷに
どうしてくれるんですか今までで一番お母さんに怒られたことは親の500円玉貯金
からお金に住んでいた時にいつも奢られたんですけど
あああ
ほどねありますね r ですね山田さんだとわかります
我なんだろうなぁガラス割っちゃった時からを打つので家の小学生ラインとで高学年的
な価値とむしゃくしゃして家に帰ってきてよなんか薄い座布団あったんですよジャブと
思っていこうカラスのところでバーンたバレエんと笑っ
はいマインしたらこんなを使った分作詞です音が割れる伴う
人参三保今度こそ食べるのだこれはたさんなく
たサナナじゃないか山田さドラマ赤い1基本的のな馬ですか7800も
仰はなんかここが半分行ったことないですけどね
なっているお腹ですよね一どんだというかについ食べてください
アウディガス土の味が好きでよかったで不倫系湘南でそんな髪がなお花子さんの勉強
趣味と言うとよさき店という
買っちゃいますよ
撮れなかったじゃん俺普通のおっ
3バックナンバーん
[音楽]
花いっぱいに仕事の上司の意見が人によって違っていてとても困っています
のホーム指示に従ったらもう片方から文句を言われ事情説明してもいいわけだと言われ
てしまいますこういうときどうしたらいいでしょうか
待った大人が多いねぇこれはこれ
そういう経験ありますかありますよあのたとえ現場で監督がこうやって言ってた話だ後
に
じゃあカメラの場合提案
1個の助監督で違うこと言っ
そろそろがはっきりました岬こうやっているおっしゃってたんですけども
すり合わせて覚えてもいいですか
言い訳に面倒くさがってる実結局んです
もその責任転換させずに
その人の成長のためも思って
杏ちゃんと言ってあげることがいいと思いますよね
みてください大根で鼻ほじってほしいです
何でもそれでちょっと入らないかもしれない
何でもそれじゃないぜもうダメではだからこんなことしたいっ
意見書いけないのならは方ちょっと待って逆だこれでこっちだ
逆に危ないですまたな白が勝っきっとてしまい逆に電話院で見よう
小
尼崎さんと山田孝之です
pe フ
あの今肇社長の宅にお邪魔しています
お金なのですか
はいそうですねあの味が社長がねあの質問コーナーをさぼってたのでちょっとやり
なさいということできまして
であの人に質問中にあの正樹さんに電話を知ろうということがあったので今の電話し
ます
まずに何か伝えたいことはないのかこんな機会ないぞ
[音楽]
あのたねうん昨日久しぶりに赤髪にしてい
こさせてるなみかんおいしいよさあ一口で食べていいかむしろ
はいはいはい
c 250
も食べてみたい逃げる
れないんね
フェイ
自分でも背筋を
持った
ん
[音楽]
ぽよぽよパートナーカヌーンっぽいつなぎバック不具合
チェックしてー
銀髪
ヨナさんはなんか楽しくなってきちゃったパターンだですやめましょうね
本気の糞んちゃーん
me
ジャンとして一緒にして女性の服に変身
僕はいいんですけどね皆さまっ
東友がこちらです山田さんおっぱいは大好きですか
大好きです本気でレーダーの真似してほしい林ポーターカーン
あろろなぁ
ヒューズここにいろれたなはい
まだ大丈夫とこの方です
んです com 期ごとにボブ好き
さんってこんなことまでやってくれるんですか
+ので頭殴ってください
もっとぶつけてデー
持っています
気にするなんて行けにするよ気にするんだよなんだこれは
大丈夫すを大丈夫を受けないだー
本当にありがとうございました今度は少しはございませんおかげさまで質問コーナーが
無事できました
やっとですねあ当然ちゃん店なきゃだめですよはいなくても
追加あっちょいけませんまあでも本当にはじめたちはホント救世主なので猫全然ここ
までやることができました
ああいう中フェイスアーム肇社長のおかげなので僕のおかげ庵の精度が多くの人を
つくってくれたので音を受け全然今名前も安いもんですよ
奈良
シャツありがとう
こっちですねそれをちょっと見えていただいてまたこれは何ですか
なんかせ金額が書いてあるんですけど
はい
本当にありがとうございます
a 棟そうですね
この撮影日の2日前からですね
私プロデュース監督していますあの臓器裏続きっていうものはの上映してるんですけど
今このご時世は席を空けなきゃいけないんですよね
阿蘇ですねそうするとですねやっぱもとしても困ってしまうんですよ
なのであの肇社長にですねその空いてる空席を買っていただいています音といいから
ってそれおととい抱えいただいてますか
ていただいてますでこのような感じになっておりますねこれ刈谷に地域という愛知県な
んですけどこれが入っているセキュアの肇社長の顔があってありますまずじゃないです
よね
ねかつじゃないすかも全部あのこれ伏見ミリオン座じゃまずで知らないやとして我々と
カップリング渋谷のですね
おろしですねタイプ
肇社長ありがとうえっこれを食わせ下よく敵を買ってくれましたこれで本当に知らない
華麗でこの劇場さんもうみんな映画業界も助かってですね100発で埋まっちゃったん
でね
ってちゃんと守ってますから人がいないですかなでこれあの
ペット今ですねさん劇場で
を上演していまして
その分の道1週間ですかねグー積分になりますそれはこの226万円644円そうです
ねほどくださいホラー
皆さん大感謝ですよねこれまで言うか
録画ズっぽいですよねがちです
[音楽]
アンチャー時あのシャツ始めた超の高 youtube の9 r は本当ならござい
ますを持っているつい最後じゃ確定でスマホ200はもう勝手ですからね
いやー頑張ったなぁ今日取りなんかなだんだんこんなことしないんだよねー
その通りですねねぇ
払わせくださいこれはもうはい確定の脱走後で見るとこちらの技をお話しさせていたら
分かりませんラッキー
うらそく
[音楽]
おっ
ブーブー
あった
[音楽]